okay so today we're gonna be talking
about units and in particular the
weirdest units of the weird and
wonderful ones I'm gonna limit myself to
the ones that are actually used in
physics literature today because
otherwise we'd be here all day talking
about pirate ninjas on Mars and
measuring bridges in Smoots
so this is gonna be from my own
experiences in research a little bit of
research I've done and then also just
talking to people on Twitter
units are important we should care about
units there was once a hundred and
twenty five million dollar unit error in
the Mars climate orbiter in 1999
basically us JPL were expecting the
units of thrust in Newton's per second
normal SI unit of thrust whereas
Lockheed Martin gave it to them in pound
force per second satellite entered Mars
orbit to shallow and it exploded in the
atmosphere and everyone swear it was
lost people should care about units
always write the unit's so what I want
to start with is the one that when I was
learning physics I thought was the
weirdest it is a parsec so a lot of
people might be familiar with the parsec
was that famous line in Star Wars the
Millennium Falcon made the Kessel run in
12 parsecs which makes people think that
it's a time but it's not it's a distance
the way that it is a fine is actually in
terms of an angle it's really quite
strange so it's all to do with this
thing called parallax the named parsec
comes from a portmanteau of parallax an
arcsecond which is an angle parsec
everybody probably at some point has
done this where they put their finger up
in front of their face and then like
closing one eye and then open it so like
oh look my thing is on the left hand
side of your face Brady on the right
hand right hand side I'm not even my
finger yeah I I wasn't trying to wave it
again and so basically what's happening
there is that the foreground object is
moving with respect to the background
object Brady with respect to like what
angle I am viewing my finger at and if I
move my finger away from my face and
closer to it moves a smaller angle and a
bigger angle the same thing happens with
stars so foreground stars moving with
respect of the background stars at the
constellations
so in terms of like where the earth is
in in winters left eye and where the
earth is in summer my right eye sees a
star move
a certain angle with respect to the
background stars and you work out that
that angle actually corresponds to a
distance use trigonometry and the
distance from the earth the Sun so it
turns out that a parsec is about 3 times
10 to the 16 meters a parsec is 30
petter meters we don't go around saying
things like you know that the Sun is 5
micro parsecs away it's definitely only
used for distances outside the solar
system the cool thing is it scales
really well so nearby stars are like 10
to a hundreds of parsecs galaxies are
kiloparsecs across galaxies are
separated by mega parsecs and then the
universe itself is Giga PASOK's
across so this comes from the idea of a
Hubble length you know what's the
distance to the farthest object that we
can observe and that's about 4.5 Giga
parsecs and that's also similar to the
hubble time as well which is the best
estimate for the age of the universe 14
Giga years billions of years kicking in
so if it feels really weird to me to
talk about distances in terms of angle
shifts why wouldn't you just calculate
the distance and I had a little put down
from someone on Twitter for my
millennial ways and they said to me
folks wouldn't think parsec was so weird
if their professional career extended
back to the time when electronic
calculators were Rarity's owned by
university departments so bill keel
professional astronomer in alabama put
me in my place an electron volt it's not
a voltage nope do you know what it is
instead yeah so it's not a voltage it's
an energy of an electron basically so
it's the energy that an electron gains
moving through a voltage of 1 volt so
obviously electricity comes from the
movement of particles with charges and
protons and electrons protons tend to be
locked into atoms so it's the electrons
that move so it makes a lot of sense
when you think about it like that but
the reason that I think it's weird is
that it's not a defined unit it's an
empirical unit it comes from measurement
so to actually refer to an electron volt
in an experiment you have to have
actually measure what the energy gained
by the electron is over 1 volts because
it's not necessarily like defined like
say the speed of light is defined it's a
measurement unit and and so I think
that's kind of weird how it becomes the
sort of like self-referential kind of
unit so if you do measure an electron
volt it comes out at one point
times 10 to the minus 19 joules or 16 at
Oh Jules if you prefer so atomic physics
nuclear physics particle physics they
all deal with the tiny things in our
universe and so these kind of energies
are appropriate for those fields cool
thing is though it's not often used as
energy unit it's used as a mass unit
yeah so if we think about what Einstein
told us e equals MC squared energy and
mass are equivalent
once we've measured how much energy an
electron has in this one volt we then
can know its mass if we divide it by C
squared so a lot of times that you see
electron volt is actually quoting the
mass of these tiny tiny particles
instead you just have to remember that
there's this divided by C squared unit
that's there as well that you have to
not forget an electron nor point five
one one mega electron volts per C
squared
and that might sound really strange but
like most undergrad physicists will
probably know that off the top of their
head in mega electron volts four C's
good which is kind of cool right the
Higgs boson that's 125 Giga electron
volts this is good and so again this
idea of like the the prefix of the
unit's gives you an idea of how much
bigger in terms of an electron the Higgs
boson really is it's one of those
massive particles we know so it's an
energy but sometimes used as a mass so
Brady have you ever heard of snoo B yeah
Newby's my favorite record it's not like
Snoopy's cousin its rapid its newbie so
anything this is one my favorites do be
it stands for supernova unit in the B
band so basically what it is is the
number of supernovae per century
per 10 to the power of 10 solar
luminosities in the B band
yeah basically what it boils down to is
number of so you put over per century
per galaxy because galaxies are about
sort of 10 billion solar luminosities
each ish about 2 to 3 for the Milky Way
so I mean it probably the smallest
number astronomy has so how could it
give us that really even a 2 to 3 Snoopy
galaxy exactly 2 to 3 Snoopy's you can
do this in any astronomical wave band so
you know this is the range of
wavelengths that you look at to tell
what amount of light that you're getting
an optical and thread so that can be u
bv RI g z YJ h KL m and
cute so you can have Snoopy snoot K snug
and the Newsies yeah you could have
smoothies as well I wouldn't know
whether it'd be like five snooze ease
rather than like two to three Snoopy's
for the Milky Way I don't know but I
just want the idea that like
professional super nova restaurant up is
going around going oh yeah that one's
like three Snoopy's i guess that would
get same therefore the names just too
much fun
okay so let's break this down Kerma for
kinetic energy released per unit mass
anything about like a radioactive atom
how much kinetic energy it releases air
kurma is you know how much kinetic
energy is released per unit mass into a
unit mass of air so how much energy the
air then absorbs air coma strength is
then you know how much energy is
deposited into the air at a distance
away from the radioactive source squared
okay so air kurma is obviously its
energy so that's measured in just joules
per kilogram but then people refer to
that as a gray instead which is
shortened capital gy
not to be confused with a gig year which
is capital g yr and so that's a gray and
then you've got that in terms of you
know the rate so it's per hour as well
but it's you know air chemist strength
so it's this distance away so it's the
Gray's per hour per meter squared okay
and they decided that was too
complicated of a unit to to work in and
so they gave it a new name you want to
know what they called this unit unit
they called it unit and it has just a
capital u it's just it's just it's so
ridiculous but they just call it you'd
it like how lazy can you pay so one or
arrogant yeah good yeah it's just this
is the defining unit one you one unit is
a micro gray per meter squared per hour
an ERG it's not like an unsure leg it's
actually a unit of energy so most of the
units that we come across every day are
you know like meters seconds kilograms I
mean like there are a part of a unit
system that's actually defined it's
called the SI units basically the define
system but and so in the SI units your
standard unit of energy is joules people
are quite familiar with
that instead you can work in a
completely different system of units
which is called CGS or centimeters grams
per second okay and that's your base
system that all your units are built up
and the base energy unit in that system
is eggs okay because my son a little bit
weird people but back at the turn of
like sort of a century of the 1802 1900s
this was the preferred system of unit
Maxwell was a big fan of working in CGS
and he wanted that to become like
adopted across all fields this is one of
these sort of historical units that was
was in use then in in a lot of areas of
physics because you know centimeters
Graham's second when you're thinking
about early physics in like labs those
are the kind of scales that you're
working with right you're working with
grams of substance across centimeters in
terms of seconds so it made total sense
thing is cuz it's tradition there are
some fields that still use it problem
it's the fields that still use this it's
astronomy where they're done quoting
energies released from black holes like
10 to the 44 eggs per second and energy
released from supernova of 10 to the 51
eggs
it just is such a ridiculous unit to now
work in so if you think about energy we
think about maybe calories as well one
calorie is forty one bigger eggs so that
I'll give you an idea of how small an
egg is and so this is why you see in
astronomy is ridiculous right so much so
the supernova scientist again these
pesky super noted scientists just
inventing units they decided that most
supernovae are about 10 to the 51 eggs
so they invented a new unit which is a
foe which comes from 10 to the 51 eggs
so a foe is 10 to the 51 X and so law go
around saying okay let's supernova went
off with like two foe or like 3.2 foe
you look so gangster the only time I've
ever looked gangster astronomy and I
have to say this one probably got the
most hate on Twitter like there are so
many frustrated astronomers out there I
have to use this unit and they just hate
it the Jansky
and it's used a lot in radio astronomy
so it's all about the flux density that
you have from a radio source how much
energy you're actually getting from that
radio source per sort of unit angle on
the sky so a Jansky is defined as 10 to
the minus 26
watts per square meter per Hertz so
you're working in so Hertz is out which
is the frequency of radiation you're out
the frequency of the radiation you want
to know in terms of like per meter
squared because that's your collecting
area of your actual sort of CCD as well
and then your watts is obviously the
amount of energy that you're actually
getting from it but you've also had to
integrate over the angle that you were
on in the sky as well and the way that
the Jansky is defined is that you have
to integrate over a unit angle which is
called the stir Radian so a stayer
Radian is basically just a square Radian
just a weird word for it so you have to
integrate over square radians on the sky
as well so it's just this horrendous
unit especially if you never come across
it before so I kind of feel like it's a
little bit of a barrier to entry for a
lot of students that come to Radio
Astronomy as well in the fact that it's
such a weird unit and also just
conversion from that unit two units that
people are used to working with in like
optical studies instead like if you want
to do like a comparative you know I have
my source and I've seen it in the
optical but now how much energy is it
having the radio and how does that
compare you obviously have to convert
those units to the same unit to be able
to compare them which brings me on to my
next unit which is related which was
called the Nano Maggie I just think of
like tiny Maggie Simpson the Nano Maggie
which is about three point six times ten
to the minus six jean skis three point
six micro G on skis is what the Nano
Maggie is defined as and it comes from
sort of your zero point in the magnitude
system that you're working with this
magnitude is like brightness system in
astronomy and it's just this huge mess
still so it's on my list because it's
cause astronomers so much frustration
over the years this is a paper from
astronomers again and they're studying
molecular cloud densities so that the
clouds that are gonna form stars the gas
it's all going to condense to form stars
they're looking at how dense they are in
the universe and what the pressure is in
these clouds as well that's gonna squish
them together so sentence is more over
some of the highest column density
clumps would require enormous confining
pressures of roughly a thousand to a
billion Kelvin per centimeter cubed so
that was a pressure
in kelvins per centimeter cubed Kelvin a
unit of temperature and centimeter cubed
a unit of volume so they're quoting
pressures in temperatures per volume
most the time pressures are done in
atmospheres or bars as well here they're
doing it in kelvins per centimeter cubed
which probably doesn't make any sense
until you think about the context so in
space the gases that you're dealing with
the gases you're modeling here they're
very low density there's barely any
interactions you know there's no
collisions and so basically what we call
that is an ideal gas so we might
remember that from high school ideal
gases okay let can beam always modeled
as an ideal gas and so that means that
we can apply the ideal gas law which
people might remember PV equals NRT P
being the pressure V being the volume n
is the number of moles of an element R
being a constant and then T being the
temperature astronomers change this so
that they're working in the number of
actual atoms they've got because they
can kind of estimate the number a so
because it's such a low density they
rearrange it so that it's P equals
number of atoms divided by the volume
times by the Boltzmann constant times
temperature and they basically just say
drop the Boltzmann constant and then
they say the pressure is there for the
temperature of the volume and so
basically everybody knows that when they
quote these numbers of like a thousand
to a billion Kelvin per centimeter cubed
but there's some Boltzmann constant in
there that they haven't taken into
account but they don't say it it's just
that everybody knows that it's there
which I think it's just really lazy and
also they haven't dumped this unit I
feel like if this unit should be dub
like they're lazy or something like it's
just they need to give it a name if
they're gonna keep using it because it's
really strange and it would really
confuse people especially people like
new to the field that have never even
come across this before last but not
least is a barn you've heard a barn
before like barn conversions or like
sheds and stuff okay so a barn is using
particle physics all the time it's a
cross-sectional area of a particle okay
so it's about a hundred femtometers
squared its defined us so that's 10 to
the minus 28 meters squared it's about
the cross-sectional area of a uranium
nucleus so the reason it's called a barn
it comes from the u.s. expression
couldn't hit the broadside of a barn
which means that your aim is terrible
basically so obviously the idea of
particle
because you're trying to get two
particle beams to collide no Amy just be
good so you need to be able to hit a
bond and so they they talk about you
know one bond cross-sectional area or we
know we got to hit that target within
like point by bond I presume I presume
that's what like the control centers
if these particle physics experiment for
like the cross-sectional area of a
particle you know you've always got
something tiny times by something tiny I
was even smaller so that's why they
needed a new unit I'll give them that
it's not an SI unit necessarily but it
is recognized by them as a unit because
it's used so much in the field as well
similar to a Jansky actually there's
also technically the outhouse which is a
micro barn and the shed which is a Yocto
barn the thing that I love about bonds
is that you basically have a tiny area
okay
and what about if we combined a tiny
area with a very large distance so if
you remember we had a very large
distance of beginning we had parsecs and
we were talking about the Hubble
distance being like 4.5 Giga parsec okay
and if we combine a very small area and
a very large distance we get a volume
okay but very very tiny area and very
very large distance gives you a volume
that's actually quite reachable to like
everyday volumes combined a barn in a
mega parsec you get a barn megaparsec
which is about the size of a teaspoon
yeah which I really really like remember
our Hubble length before was a 4.5 Giga
PASOK's
so you can have a Hubble bond which
again is a volume and it's about 13
liters so you could talk about like
filling up your car with like rubber
bands if you wanted or like my car get
so many cobble burns miles per Hubble
bond which i think is really really nice
so that got me thinking whether we could
use these crazy units in something more
everyday
perhaps like a cake recipe and perhaps
we could have a physics inspired cake
recipe all in crazy units yeah yeah yeah
okay I actually got a cake recipe you
made one I actually well I acquired a
cake recipe yeah from maryberry
obviously yeah and I rewritten her cake
recipe yeah to be physics yeah yeah I
feel like this should be read in like my
most be
see RP accent what do you think yeah
yeah okay okay preheat the oven to give
an output flux density in the infrared
regime of seven Yocto nano Maggie's then
make sure to grease in line to 6.5 at Oh
parsecs sandwich tins break for eggs
that's eggs not eggs into a large mixing
bowl then mix in 126 Yasha
electron volts for speed of light
squared of both sugar and flour with two
barn megaparsecs
of baking powder and naught point naught
six humble bonds of butter divide the
mixture evenly between the two tins and
bake the cakes on the middle shelf of
the oven for three femto Hubbell types
sandwich together with Jam once cool and
sprinkle over some castor sugar for
decoration and there you have it a
physics inspired Victoria sponge cake
[Music]
you